[Applaudissements]
seuls camille lâché découvriez j'y
arriverai pas j'y arriverai de 6 passes
bertrand sa page rouleau pourquoi t'as
vu ta chronique dire si c'est pire
t'as vu ta chronique d'avant-hier alors
j'ai eu la presse alva france
télévisions dans le cul ouais je vous
traduis rega ont fait apparemment c'est
mort pour la candidature de série la
france télévisions ne prendront pas y
être
bertrand qu'es-tu ball et jus de pomme
ouais c'est du jus de pomme parce qu'en
fait on n'a pas le budget enfin on n'a
pas le droit pour le hockey mais coup de
poing en l'air on ne touche pas à mon
poste mais je vire une bonne chose que
toi tu es mon pote l'histoire comme un
seigneur décès il s'érige connaissiez
pas né sur les mots
coûte on aura tout tenté 1 ça n'a pas
pris on aura tout tenté mais attends
c'est bon c'est mort c'est pas mort
c'est mort pour france télé oui d'accord
mais on peut encore le faire devenir
président d'une autre chaîne et prendre
sa place l'an prochain mais oui mais
quelle chaîne alors je voulais pas
sortir la cartouche à manger les guider
h de moyenne le faire devenir président
de la chaîne numéro 23
mais ça n'existe pas numéro 23 s'est pas
une chaîne et si si si ça existe donc
faire son côté une chaîne numéro 23 h et
numéro un site mois un animateur de
numéro 23 ou un programme e
ouais bon ok question piège je te dis
qu'on peut le faire devenir pdg et même
le pdg actuel et en alternance et 71,1
c'est vrai que maman tu me le dis sur ma
télécommande j'ai pas le réflexe je fais
21 22 le vainqueur et oui les jeux et je
sai paquet c'est le problème de la
chaîne numéro 23 ans et que personne ne
viendra donc bombay arquette safer toi
tout autre chose
sais-tu quelle est la durée de gestation
d'une maman baleine 12h22 d'accord et
est ce que tu as regardé le tube samedi
avec six aides en invité ouais j'ai vu
est payante
il s'est dit des choses assez
intéressante chamerois il va avoir des
nouvelles choses l'année prochaine et
jolie des reproches à me roy il va être
ils on va le voir encore plus sur des
beats à gauche
ouais j'ai vu le quand il dit plus c'est
plus n'aura cette année là c'est le
boulot toyas - et là c'est plus vraiment
c++ plus exposés et c'est d'ailleurs
c'est plus par rapport à juillet et
exemple on s'en fout au hasard par
rapport à moi c'est pas plus par rapport
à -6 et c'est plus que toi aussi
ouais parce que toi mais ce fin tu l'as
pris quand même quoi samedi chez moi
ouais mais pas du tout mais pas du tout
les eaux et la guerre de qui fait plus
qui fait moi ça princeps savamment
j'avais peur qu'il ya un malaise entre
moi du tout pas du tout bertrand nouvel
échelon allez ciao ciao un nom c'est le
rhume des foins
je
manque quelqu'un
- enfin c'est pas non plus un drame un
allié les copains ryanair poule à qui on
a vu à la télévision française avant
pour the stars qui se sait ses enfants y
couche sans d'état et on lire touchante
et pandev senoussi sinon s'il vous ces
digues le même temps qu est-ce qu en
train de faire là bertrand
j'ai appris la nouvelle
camille nous a quittés [ __ ] de camion
alors c'est triste mais on va pas passer
la semaine dessus non plus donc je fais
un peu de rangement sur son bureau
et dès demain je récupère sa chronique
et puis ensuite on finit la fin de
saison et l'année prochaine ou la
nouvelle grande scène
c'est bibi bertrand il a juste une
angine camille c'est à dire bah et
l'angine quoi il a des poux blanc sur la
gorge il a mal quand il avale mais ça va
quoi il sera là demain pour faire sa
chronique
demain ouais 2 me et puis finira la
saison
enfin tout va bien d'accord bascoul 1
allée hier champion et bertrand six mois
si loser